Phoenix are looking to silence the
haters and stun the world with their own
style of league of legends they are
pushing onto the Nexus the favorites of
g2 in Paris did not stand a chance not a
lot of people found that fun plus
Phoenix could win world final they were
misfits
they played a weird style they were
unconventional plain flippy
dark forces at best that last somehow
Arctic assault boats of the Lorcan in
every match against every opponent they
were doubted the cynics always went back
to their weird offbeat style and their
middle II who refused to play by the
rules analysts predicted their defeat at
every turn - alright explain yourselves
why so much confidence I mean I believe
that g2 is the better version of FPS but
with every victory
FBX proved their style and win that even
if they look like five unlikely
champions individually together they
were unbeatable
Vulcan unlike the best team from pretty
much every other major region fpx aren't
a super team they joined the LPL in 2018
and their debut season wasn't anything
special and with a 3-1 victory they
closed it out taking the series and
advancing to quarters there was still
fighting at the X but jdg finished
strongly but they headed into 2019 with
a new roster featuring Tionne in the
jungle and an unusual mid laner join me
but 2019 was doing B's last shot at a
title after failing to make worlds again
in 2018 he was ready to call it quits
but soon will Cheney empathizes some
sushi my email from the renter posted
out similar Cynthia consider Omaha and I
want to join me then a young Korean
player moved to China in 2015 and
quickly picked up a following thanks to
his weird off meta pics
charity education hi Tom Walkinshaw
Chung Chung denied her journey you gotta
go to the usual get hot juicy initiative
not so injured hardware - yo my man
Amanda hold on to each other - pooja ho
Calatrava to Khandala cheats on you
dinosaur Canada young but join me was
more than just porky flash he had the
skills to back up the weirdness
he made Finals in his first season as a
pro proving that his playstyle was more
than just gimmicks it was effective so
it's gonna dive in for the kill insects
super job takes the next one there an
insect just gonna keep rolling out
Terauchi but joy be doing enough the CC
train is massive and they're just gonna
dive in you is gonna die as well join me
we'll go in for the trade but zero
couldn't make it I Luigi and tumblr
sayin BPRD defiant I was able to keep
their Guardian children from the same
difficulty but for all of doing these
accolades he still had an empty trophy
case sure he won MVP multiple times but
he'd never won a finals he'd never
attended Worlds his last attempt to make
worlds ended with a 3-1 loss to EDG in
the 2018 regional qualifier team has to
be respected Edward gaming always and
forever best of the LPL and after trying
and failing so many times
Dobby was ready to take a break from pro
play makes itself home I know I could
sell this or tomato juice you know what
so now I placed there to initiation
Ashima
I want a homogeneous oval common such as
it hits the
Josua like oh ha ha Maori Party double
time system myself but there was one
person who believed in join me one
person who told him to just give it one
more shot for one more year
his wife whenever doing B's playing
she's there leading the fans to cheer
for him and his team by the smallest
amount even though there are LGD chance
at the venue as well you can hear duo
B's wife and you can hear the passion
behind FBX yep chant leader has been
since day one through the good and the
bad knee supported doing these endeavors
as a pro player and convincing him to
stick around for one more year ended up
being the greatest advice he received in
whole four years of his career right now
I really want to thank you for all your
company before this I was contemplating
retirement and it was you who told me to
believe in myself and give it one more
year join me was the star that fpx
needed because of his weird quirky play
style we've joined me in the middle and
the team went from middle of the pack to
third he was even named league MVP in
the spring but people expected going me
to be solid on fpx what they didn't
expect was the rise of their new jungler
Tionne before joining FEX
he was the substitute jungler on the
middling suiting gaming but after
joining the team he went from a reserve
to China's best jungler
being he's in half health tan the dragon
flag again the flag is giving it another
route to the spine to flash-forward Tan
there's a shield there but he gets it
anyway chunk will come back comes to a
close and be able to pick up that kills
you and T on isn't just individually
talented he also perfectly called went
to join these businesses are placed on
[Music]
px finished first in both the spring and
summer regular season but they fumbled
in the spring playoffs summer though was
another story entirely they all see
while dough makes a busy in the unified
composition junior comes in with a blank
they pull him back they turn back around
picnic time to help lhasa play around
city gets ignited around if you hold up
the I boy coming up down this step below
step jump run picked up punk Adobe hey
princess WL elements over the wall
pollution weight how to lose weight like
game FBX on it
this game is bonkers doing watch the
board on 2 kasa
the shield not enough to save the day
three books one showers feels the front
of an inbuilt MPX you thought they were
gonna slow down even Rosie coming up
dating the trade up support be good
enough to flush it all over each other
this thing get out movie it need to help
a big the [ __ ] Rome lwx
Haiti Kerry votes ad carry after all
that time stumbling at the finish line
join me was finally heading to world
thanks in no small part to guys like T
on and crisp fpx weren't really
well-known outside of China but they
were respected as the top seed from a
major region at least until they load it
onto the riff for their first group
stage match the biggest upset of the day
you have to believe jteem pushing it
right down mid no one can stop them J
team are just going to take the game
fun plus here a huge tournament maemura
coming in it was supposed to be the easy
group for them but J team are going to
beat them
what an incredible results a team takes
down fun plus Phoenix fbx had an
underwhelming start to world not only
did they lose their first game they
almost lost their second two they were
only saved by a miracle play from T on
looking to try and get in there we've
seen this before there was TX eventually
topped their group but it wasn't ready
they needed point me to carry stoppable
force a perfect ability for a team pitch
dominant as you can imagine after group
stage of that sloppy some analysts begin
to doubt FP x1 plus I still think it
should be disappointing guess they're
gonna be happy that they got first see
but that feels more like relief and
happiness because a lot of people that
I've talked to they casters an analyst
coming to this event peg this as the
worst group in world's history heading
in the quarterfinals some analysts were
putting their money on fnatic not FPS
and given how rocky their group stage
performance was it was hard not to feel
like their bets were right
FEX versus fnatic I actually this one
for me is actually maybe the easiest one
to call me I think it's gonna be fnatic
yeah meanwhile the European crowd was
against fpx from day one but amidst the
horde of haters there was who me waving
the FBX flag for a husband
all right teleports coming in as the
dock up landing on too reckless he
decides to turn back to the tower but
this is an easy kill crisp is the one
that gets the credit and assigns low on
mana the Tarte anchor has been swapped
Ian goes loaded survived by 80 HP now
the table turns to lwx
there's a trade one for one but three
members stand H I can tick minion wave
and the turret places I just will chase
board with the killer instinct to
continue slowed our cards get in range
that boomerang plate does so much to
reengage
reckless under the tower they get the
top Tower they extend the gold leaves
and this game is already feeling over
there are super minions on the skips of
fanatics base death from below comes out
do be forced to flash or at least moving
away with the flash and Hennis ex
already gave the inhibitor fall there
goes Brooks are trying to get some
damage confusing trouble why sometimes
hexakill tomatoes that's a dead chemist
dead it's going to be a dead fanatic fpx
earned their spot in the semi-finals
where they were gonna face off against
Invictus gaming the defending world
champions IG were the only team to take
a match off of fpx in summer but world's
fpx were out for blood
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes is dominant wins over fnatic and IG
washed away their group stage road they
were even building up a Western fanbase
thanks both to their performance and
join these antics but some experts
weren't sold on FBX or Adobe's
unorthodox play style is done capella no
faker know having done this from a my
opinion is one of the worst meets of the
tournaments through all of doing these
games you can literally pinpoint how
poorly is actually playing the lane poor
auto-attacks poor positioning but at
this point FBX only had one way to win
over their critics winning their next
match and a lifting the summoner's Cup
FP X's final opponents were the kings of
Europe
the team always coming up with new
strategies the favourites to win it all
g2 eSports
from Europe a world record g2 eSports
three if 2019 League of Legends was an
anime g2 were the protagonist their
skill and flexibility took the world by
storm
here's the thing they come play whenever
the [ __ ] they weren't he's unbelievable
so heading into finals g2 were
undefeated and best of matches all year
they went both LEC splits Hinda
midseason Invitational if they won
worlds they'd be the first team in
history to win the grand slam but in the
finals fpx gave thousands of g2 fans a
reality check now under pressure that is
very heartening to see all right there's
the engage that kick back Mickey finds
some damage on Dewey but he's instantly
thrown to the Wolves the charge from
gamegune bring some service factors when
those golden objects stays alive win
will buy some time but simply not enough
bugs goes forward the final breath does
nothing and it's crisp that gets another
two quick kills - FPA yeah connects over
the war heroes enters into the river and
g2 they cannot find anything yet they're
chasing us because they've got themself
kill the tough who comes up and give
dude he doesn't have to charge available
at all
two three don't be wet kept fighting the
triple to get some not luck G to our
East at 22 minutes
FBX trying to collapse here now g2 will
they get him alright come in this could
be it for G 2 LW x goes forward before
finally kill T anchors but there is a
potential
observers once again silence the haters
and stun the world on to the next
[Applause]
fpx decimated Jeju defeating the
favourites three Oh they silenced the
European crowd and lifted the summoner's
Cup as the best team in the world aren't
your typical champions they aren't
flashy and they're super carry mid laner
prefers tanks and supports to meet
immunity Bob water continental now
punchy anyway SWAT at all so don't
forget the time pain upon June Pantene
gentlemen alicorn you chose amulets as
you Walter don't pop I cannot you see
Jake agility oh but thanks to them he
might be entering a new era of league of
legends an era where we can finally
throw out the idea that there's one
right way to play an era where finding
the perfect place all for your team will
mean so much more than just copying
another team from across the world
fpx didn't win worlds because they had
the most innovative picks or the best
late-game macro they won worlds because
they ignored the hater and play the
style that they wanted to the wonky
playstyle that made everyone fall in
love with that and it paid off
and Clara
[Applause]
so when you're fucking-a hammering
something like that can you know what
can you just stop okay he stopped